we are just one step away from a
coronavirus vaccine
authorized for use by the fda now the
move could come as soon as today as
hospitals and pharmacies
urgently prepare for its arrival
yesterday's you may have heard an
independent committee of experts
recommended approval following a
thorough review of the data
that can't come soon enough this has
been the deadliest week of the pandemic
so far more than 18 thousand people
alive and with us a week ago are now
gone a 38 percent increase over the
previous seven days
our lead national correspondent david
begno is in los angeles for us david
good morning to you
the vaccine is going to be and this puts
it lightly a huge logistical challenge
how are officials there preparing that's
right but you know major institutions
like cedar sinai here in los angeles
appear to be ready to go i'm telling you
we've been talking to them
we just got a statement from the fda
that i want to read to you following
yesterday's positive advisory committee
meeting outcome regarding the pfizer
vaccine
the fda has informed the sponsor that it
will rapidly work toward finalization
and issuance
of an emergency use authorization and
the fda says it's notified the cdc and
operation warp speed
so they can execute their plans for
timely vaccine distribution we are one
step away
from the final green light we must
demonstrate that the vaccine is highly
effective
that was the topic of discussion that
dominated the nearly nine hour long
discussion by
experts on the fda's independent
advisory committee on vaccines
the american public demands and deserves
a rigorous comprehensive and independent
review of the data
quoted yes in a 17 to four vote with one
abstention
they concluded that the pfizer vaccine
is safe and effective for
emergency use for those 16 and older
even with recent concerns about allergic
reactions in two health care workers in
the united kingdom
i would not hesitate to get the vaccine
i've got a lot of allergies
i plan to get the vaccine that is dr
arnold monto
he is the acting chair of that
independent advisory committee
he says the vaccine needed to be at
least 50 percent effective for it to
receive the committee's recommendation
this vaccine is in excess of 90 percent
that's almost a dream scenario
did you vote yes or no i voted yes
enthusiastically right now hospitals
nationwide are preparing to receive the
first shipments of the vaccine and that
could happen as early as this weekend
this is the freezer inside of los
angeles cedar sinai hospital where the
vaccine will be kept
once we take the vaccine out of the
freezer we have five days in the
refrigerator
that's rita shane chief pharmacy officer
here at cedars-sinai
she has reviewed the vaccine data and
she says reports about allergic
reactions in the united kingdom
don't raise any alarm bells for her
allergic reactions are something that do
occur with everything we take even food
and the allergic reactions aren't as
concerning as getting covet and so the
focus is on
keeping us safe the vaccine will come
with a warning label but the head of
pharmacy here at cedar sinai says the
annual flu shot comes with a warning
label about potential allergic reactions
so she has no concern at all that's
right david thank you